My gender is emoji pizza unicorn: shipping
expanded gender options
Tilde Ann Thurium
Live captioning by White Coat Captioning
>> Hi, welcome back everybody.
Hope you have been checking out the amazing
things here at JSConf.
There has been some absolutely brilliant stuff
out there.
This is the best conference I have been to,
the food, there's yoghurt trucks, everything,
I'm absolutely adoring it.
So we've got our next speaker coming up.
They've come all the way over from San Francisco.
I'm hoping they've got over the jet lag by
now.
Their Twitter file introduced me to the word
engi-queer which I'm loving and I am going
to take as a job title from now, so please
give a warm round of applause for Tilde Ann
Thurium.
TILDE: Hi.
My name is Tilde, and I'm here to tell the
story of how I built and shipped expanded
gender options at Pinterest.
Some things I am going to cover are: why do
expanded gender options in product matter;
how we design the future and measure its effectiveness;
and what I learned.
So gender forms.
Whenever I'm signing up for a new app or service,
and I come across those not so fun radio buttons
that only have male or female, I feel a lot
of feelings.
Most of them are not good ones.
I have a lot of thoughts like: why?
Why are you asking me for this information?
There are a lot of reasons why genders get
baked into product.
There are maybe medical reasons, there might
be legal or compliance reasons, but mostly
it's demographics or marketing, like ad targeting.
I'm not saying these are good reasons, I'm
just saying this is why it happened.
When I first signed up for Pinterest, way
before I started working there, I noticed
those fun radio buttons that reinforced the
gender binary and little did I know that I
would soon be in a position to change that.
But how did I get there?
Software engineering is not my first career.
I have a degree in gender studies and then
I spent about five years working [sound problem]
... but then I got tired of working emotional
labour on behalf of a major corporation so
I quit my job, learned to code and got my
very first engineer job at Pinterest.
I was shit terrified.
I had no idea what I was doing and basically
was convinced I would be fired at any moment.
Somehow I managed to work through all that
pain, confusion, fear and terror, and learned
a bunch of stuff, and now it has been three
years and I haven't been fired yet.
So yay!
Anyway, after I first got hired about a year
passed and then I started to feel more confident,
not just in my technical skills but in my
inner personal understanding of politics that
were going on around and above me and how
people actually worked together to build and
ship products.
Being the kind of stirring it up sort of person
that I am, I started some conversations about
the gender thing.
I wouldn't say those conversations were great,
but neither were they awful.
People were like: yeah, I mean this isn't
going to move our core metrics, we should
just focus on things that are.
Now, don't get me wrong, I was never under
the impression that expanded gender options
are going to move core metrics.
That's not the point.
It's the kind of feature you build because
it's the right thing to do if you want your
product to be inclusive of everybody, so ... [sound
problem] ... if I wanted this feature to exist
I was going to have to make it happen, and
I was pretty sure I can figure it out.
Also I realised that I could leverage lack
of co-ownership which was actually a big problem
across the whole organisation - code ownership.
I didn't have to ask permission because no
one owned that code.
I could just build it.
Here are back end changes I made so before
I started work on it we had this enum that
represented gender.
Someone had run an AB experiment and discovered
that if you don't force people to put in their
gender, you get more signups.
Surprise, surprise.
So what I did, I added an optional string
to the user struct to present a user's custom
gender value.
It is my firm belief that gender should be
represented by a string, not a binary value,
so that way people could put in whatever they
want, including an emoji.
What is the plural of emoji, is it emojis?
Emoji?
Anyway, emoji are getting more and more important
because as technology becomes more ubiquitous,
so does text-based communication and emoji
are a great way of adding subtext to text.
Making emoji and hell all Unicode representative
of the full spectrum of human diversity that
exists is a little outside of the scope of
my talk today but I will say that the emoji
I am showing on screen don't officially exist
yet.
Although I hope they do soon.
We are getting a non-binary emoji though in
the 2017 spec which is pretty rad.
Anyway, let's talk about internationalisation
and localisation and how they relate to gender.
People use these terms interchangeably but
they are not exactly the same.
Localisation is a process of adapting your
product, the text, the design, to work in
one specific market, so this picture here
is from the movie Inside Out.
In it, the protagonist, Reilly, she is a little
girl and she just hates broccoli, except for
in Japan where she hates green peppers, because
green peppers are a vegetable that are more
hated by children in Japan than broccoli.
Since Inside Out is a movie about feelings
and empathy it was important to get the little
details right so the movie would work cross-culturally.
So internationalisation is the more generally
used case, like let's say you kept having
this vegetable problem and you decided to
build like a vegetable injector and ship it
so that you could show users a different vegetable
base somewhere in the world and that would
be an example of internationalisation, kind
of the tools and framework that enable you
to localise in multiple languages.
A base use case for localisation, okay you
have an English string and it represents some
user face in copy.
The string has a placeholder value in it that
represents the user name.
At run time we look up the user's language
setting and then replace the string with the
string in their language, and then also replace
the placeholder value.
So if I'm a German user and my name is Tilde,
hello user name becomes hello Tilde.
Why does this matter for expanded gender options?
Well, I'm not a linguist, so bear with me,
but there's this concept of grammatical gender
that about a quarter of the world's languages
have.
Grammatically gender languages have - the
nouns have genders and you have to match the
other parts of speech in the sentence, like
verbs and so forth, with the noun.
English is not grammatically gendered but
it does still have gender baked into it in
all kinds of little places like third person
pronouns and titles, so when I first decided
to build expanded gender options for Pinterest,
I wanted to allow users to supply their preferred
pronoun too.
It's more inclusive to not only allow people
to say what their gender is but to specify
how they would like to be referred to.
Unfortunately, that didn't really work out
because the localisation provider that we
were using didn't handle gender in placeholder
strings so we had to kind of work around that.
On the plus side, the translation provider
not using gender and placeholder strings meant
that all of our user interface and copy was
already gender neutral as it refers to users.
The writing team hates it because you end
up with awkwardly worded sentences where you
are avoiding pronouns but at the same time
I did not have to do any extra work.
Oh.
This is awkward.
[Laughter]
Thank you.
I didn't have to do any extra work to make
our text work for users who don't identify
as male or female.
Who cares what the writing team thinks?
That's pretty cool.
So if you are not like Pinterest and you are
not like locked into a contract with a certain
localisation provider you have options.
I found a bunch of software packages that
support localisation of gender and placeholder
strings out of the box.
Caveat.
I have not used any of these personally, so
if you have I would love to know what your
experience is like.
Come find me after the talk or tweet at me
or something.
But man, can we talk about pronouns for a
second?
Pronouns are complicated.
I wanted to shout out for having the preferred
gender pronoun buttons, that makes my heart
warm, I hope every conference is doing that,
but anyway a lot of people who don't identify
as male or female use "they" as their preference
but there are so many pronouns out there.
A website is trying to list all the different
pronouns but how do
these concepts translate cross-culturally
and cross languages?
Some languages don't have gender pronouns
at all.
Some languages like Farsi have pronouns for
if an object is animate versus inanimate,
for example.
So make sure your copy writers and translators
are working with linguists who end the best
gender preferences in that language.
So talked about the back end, talked about
localisation stuff, then I did the front end
or the middleware and API changes, blah blah
blah, and then I made the front end changes.
The first thing I did was put user gender
on the settings page.
Politically speaking, it's pretty easy to
put user gender on the settings page.
It's like the junk draw of any application
and no one gives a shit.
A funny thing happened after I did this though.
People, even though the conversation I had
started earlier had been a little lukewarm,
people came out of the woodwork to support
me and they were like: oh, this is so cool,
what can I do to help?
I was like: well, it sure would be great if
we supported this feature on iOS and Android
as well so I was able to help people make
that happen.
It didn't solve the original problem though.
Users still had to put in their gender when
they signed up for Pinterest and I wanted
to fix that.
Unlike the - oh no - unlike the settings page
the sign-up form is very political and people
really care about every pixel on that page,
and it impacts top line metrics, so I knew
that we would need to take a more data-driven
approach.
Here are a few design iterations we went through
on the way to shipping expanded gender options
on sign-up.
The first thing I tried was putting a simple
radio button in.
When a user checks the radio button, another
text box pops up where they can put in their
gender value.
The problem with this is the sign-up code
is used in many places, which is a good thing,
right?
Don't repeat yourself.
But one of those places was this narrow little
skinny little model, and when you internationalise
text or when text is localised into longer
languages such as French or German, you need
to account for about 30% more room for that
text.
So the text didn't fit in French and German
in the skinny model.
They could have just made it wider but I didn't
want this feature coupled with a certain specific
design.
I wanted it to be more robust because I knew
I wouldn't have a lot of time to maintain
it.
I asked a design friend for his feedback or
suggestions.
This is what he came up with.
There are a couple of problems with this.
Number one, there's no universal signal or
no universal symbol that represents all users
who don't identify as male or female.
Except maybe the Prince symbol.
[Laughter]
Number two, a lot of people just straight
up can't remember which symbol means male
and which symbol means female.
And number three, this is meant to get us
around the localisation or the text length
problem, but these symbols don't work all
that well cross-culturally.
Not so fun fact: symbols of homosexuality
are illegal in Russia and a symbol for non-binary
people could fall into that category.
So really this just wasn't going to fly with
anybody.
All right, fine, I will just do the hackie
thing and move on with my life, but nope.
I was blocked.
The person who was responsible for the metrics
of the sign-up form strongly felt like this
was going to cause problems.
He was really worried that Pinterest made
demographic of conservative mid-western moms
would object.
For a little while the project stalled and
I was frustrated.
I didn't know what to do and then in the way
of tech companies, there is a re-org.
[Laughter]
Suddenly I was reporting to this person who
had blocked me before, so my first line, I
was like: look, if you want me to trust you
and be on your team then you need to get me
some face time with a designer who can help
me get this form to meet your arbitrary standards.
And you know what, he came through for me.
It's a little bit of a tricky design problem,
right, like how do you make a feature visible
for the small minority of users who really
care about it but not so visible that the
majority who might not understand or be upset
won't notice it and get pissed off?
This is what we came up with.
There's a little info icon.
When you hover over it we show a tool tip.
On the tool tip we explain why we want this
information, which is kind of important, and
then allow you to put in your custom gender
string.
After a user clicks save, we replace male
or female with the text that they typed in.
So we rolled this out as an AB experiment.
Unfortunately, signups were down about 1%.
Wamp-wamp, back to the drawing board.
I hypothesised that maybe users were unintentionally
triggering the hover interaction, getting
confused, so I said: let's make this a click
interaction.
When we tried it with a click interaction,
signups were flat, so we shipped it.
Yay!
[Applause]
Thank you, finally.
We also - I measured that people were actually
using the custom gender part because, if signups
were flat but if no one is actually using
it, then what's the point, right?
But then we took things even a step further.
I was approached by a designer on the mobile
team and she was like: hey, I'm re-doing the
whole mobile sign-up flow and why is custom
gender on web so hidden?
Can't we just put it in there with the other
options?
And I was like: you are not going to get any
argument from me about that.
This was wrapped in an AB experiment too,
of course.
It's not exactly an apples to apples comparison
because the new sign-up flow is visually very
different but the metrics are better for it
so that's what we went with.
Of course, quantitative metrics never tell
the whole story so we did qualitative user
research as well.
Sentiment towards custom gender options in
this research was positive.
People said things like: custom gender is
an awesome idea for our progressive social
climate.
We got some love on social media as well.
But the whole process got me thinking, like
why?
Why is this feature so important to me?
Why do I care so much?
Yes, so on this slide there's a movie which
some of you have clearly seen called But I'm
a Cheerleader and in this movie Megan, the
main character, has a realisation that not
everybody struggles with same sex attraction.
She is different, she is a lesbian.
Building this feature, I realised not everybody
has - feels about it, having to put gender
into their box.
But I do, I'm different, I am non-binary.
What does this mean for me?
Still figuring that out, TBH.
So just to recap, building this feature taught
me that you can leverage the chaos that will
inevitably be present in your organisation
to advance your social justice warrior agenda.
[Laughter] [Applause]
After I got the ball rolling, people came
out of the woodwork to help me.
Finally, the process of writing software,
building stuff, getting it right, getting
it wrong, can teach you about yourself in
ways that you might not expect.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Wasn't that absolutely fantastic?
That one gave me so many feels right here
in my heart organ.
It was absolutely amazing.